one of them buzzed about moments right
now is over stone commenting on pokemon
girl thought spot oh I tried to make
light of it he went a little bit a
little bit more to the heart of the
matter which i think is a really
relevant point that he made yeah I
posted something on Instagram the other
day that I thought was really funny that
was like from a press junket than we did
in London where Chris Pine and Sophia
botella were like like doing Pikachu and
I was trying to talk about my judgment
of pokemon x which people didn't take
kindly to but I just feel like look you
know I think it's it's great that people
are engaging with one another but I feel
like the ultimate goal for us should be
to be able to do that without these
devices in our hands and like I realized
that technology has evolved and there's
a lot of good that comes from that and I
have no judgment of people that are into
it but I feel like how do we facilitate
the conversation about connecting
without these devices between us and and
that's that's the point I'm kind of
trying to make but people weren't happy
you